[Musique]
alors le vote à procuration c'est super
simple je les fais des dizaines de fois
ça se passe en quatre étapes
étape numéro 1 demander à un ami d'aller
voter à votre place étape numéro 2
partez en vacances à 30,03 ils oublient
d'aller voter
l'étape numéro 4 vous rentrez de
vacances et il vous dit qu'il a voté
bon du coup les résultats les élections
on est où là auo non ça s'est bien passé
vous pouvez avoir dix mille bonnes
raisons de ne pas pouvoir vous rendre au
bureau de vote le jour des élections je
sais pas moi un saut à l'élastique un
championnat jesse khawaja week-end en
amoureux venise ou mieux l'enterrement
de votre belle-mère dans ce cas vous
pouvez faire une procuration une
procuration c'est le fait de charger une
personne d'aller voter à votre place
cette personne doit répondre à plusieurs
critères
elle doit être inscrite sur la même
liste électorale que vous peu importe
son bureau vote
autrement dit ado seulement voter dans
la même commune que courra ensuite elle
ne doit pas déjà voté pour quelqu'un
d'autre
oui un électeur ou une électrice ne peut
voter qu'à la place d'un seul résident
français
enfin ce doit être une personne de
confiance c'est très important car il
n'y a aucun moyen de vérifier qu'elle
respectera bien votre choix de vote le
jour j là vous allez me dire comment ça
marche le vote par procuration est bien
la procédure est très simple vous devez
vous rendre dans un tribunal d'instance
un commissariat ou une gendarmerie pour
ceux qui vivent à l'étranger c'est au
consulat ou à l'ambassade de france que
ça se passe
une fois dans un ces lieux vous allez
devoir remplir un formulaire cerfa nommé
vote par procuration vous inscrivez
votre identité ainsi que celle de la
personne à qui vous donner procuration
aux petites astuces perso si vous voulez
gagner du temps vous pouvez imprimer et
pré remplir ce formulaire à la maison
pour finir vous donner à la personne qui
vous accueillent les papiers elle va
vérifier votre identité et ceux chargés
de transmettre votre demande à la mairie
question délai il faut que votre
formulaire s'achemine jusqu'à la mairie
concernée par courrier au plus tard la
veille du scrutin
on observe étrangement un loup forte
affluence les semaines précédant les
élections
donc pour être sûr que votre demande
soit traitée et bien n'attendez pas le
dernier moment et vous
on reste ça se passe comme un vote
classique sauf que vous mettez deux fois
sur ce je vous donne rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouvel épisode
et en attendant n'oubliez pas de me
poser vos questions à l'adresse ci
dessous allez ciao